HE WENT BY "JOHNNY COOL."
BUT THE THING IS
THEY CALLED MY DAD
AND HIS PARTNER GEORGIE
THE GOLD DUST TWINS.
MY PRONUNCIATION'S--
I'M SORRY,
MY PRONUNCIATION'S BAD.
- THAT'S FINE.
- YOU CAN UNDERSTAND ME?
- I CAN UNDERSTAND YOU.
- YOU CAN UNDERSTAND?
- YEAH.
- GEORGIE WAS LIKE,
I GOT THIS JOB.
WE SHOULD GO DO IT.
WHAT DO YOU NEED ME
TO BURN DOWN?
ONE OF THE BIGGEST
HOTEL CONSTRUCTIONS
IN NEW ENGLAND.
THIS IS PERFECT.
SO THEY GO TO THE HOTEL.
THEY MEET UP WITH THE GUY.
THE GUY WHO HIRED HIM SAYS,
I NEED YOU TO BURN THIS PLACE
TO THE [bleep] GROUND.
I OWE A LOT OF MONEY ON IT.
I PUT TOO MUCH MONEY
INTO THE ROOMS.
INTO THE CARPETS.
I PUT TOO MUCH MONEY
INTO THE KITCHENS.
INTO THE--
INTO THE DRAPES!
AND MY DAD SAYS, NO PROBLEM.
I'M THE BEST.
THAT'S WHY YOU [bleep]
HAD ME COME.
[rock music]
SO--SO MY DAD BURNT THAT...
HOTEL DOWN.
♪
AND WHAT WAS CRAZY
ABOUT MY DAD WAS,
WHILE THE PLACE WAS BURNING,
HE WOULD STICK AROUND
AND WATCH IT BURN DOWN
WITH THE FIRE DEPARTMENT
AND EVERYBODY ELSE,
AND GO, WOW!
THAT'S A FIRE, HUH?
AND PEOPLE WOULD GO,
YEAH, THAT'S A [bleep]...
CRAZY-LOOKIN' FIRE.
AND HE'D GO, WHOO!
[bleep] THING IS--
LOOKS HOT.
UM--
[drink spills]
[laughing]
- WHERE ARE YOU GOING?
OH!
[laughs hysterically]